accueil touche pas mon cher
c'est super non pas du tout
mais pas que
j'ai fait
c'est dit
m
mon cher ballon
c'était faire les fous
ses chances
jean torton
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
douchka esposito à marseille où elle
s'est installée depuis peu avec sa
famille chez moi entrer
dernier études et sarthe si cet après
midi c'est l'effervescence chez
l'ancienne ambassadrice française de
disney c'est que ce soir là un concert
avec ses anciennes peluches des débuts
sa fille et ses deux fils la suite dans
toutes ses aventures
je vais mais un petit peu à contribution
ils sont cools ils savent le prix de ce
métier et connaisse les tenants et les
aboutissants parker puisque bon ils me
suivent depuis toujours on prend la
chienne allez c'est parti
avant de se rendre sur le lieu de son
concert pour les répétitions douchka
nous emmène faire un tour sur la
corniche la mer c'est très important je
trouve que franchement c'est une
décompression reine de la regarder en sa
compagnie nous allons visiter la maison
de pêcheur qui appartient à sa mère
l'actrice pascale petit vosgien souvent
là me baigner parce que l'eau est claire
c'est plus isolé c'est plus sauvage
c'est plus sympa la vue est formidable
il y en a qui se baignent un ras le bol
est bonne
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien c'est notre petit havre de
paix arabe de pêcheurs douchka elle ses
enfants se rendent maintenant avère qu
hier c'est dans la salle des fêtes de
cette commune à 70 km de marseille
qu'elle va se produire ce soir étoiles
et deux très jeunes fans de douchka
viennent la saluer c'est pas tout à fait
la même couleur et ses cheveux de
princesse à québec à l'heure des
répétitions douchka interprète une
chanson de son père le poète gianni
esposito et bien sûr les incontournables
tubes de l'époque disney
[Musique]
annie cordy qui voit annie cordy elle
fait l'arrêt du curé mais je suis sûr
que quand elle chante du pierre ou du
yuan donne assure que savez quoi mais
moi j'aimerais bien démarrer une
nouvelle carrière entre dit même tu vois
après c'est la scène qui positionne un
artiste
[Applaudissements]
six états d'âme
je pense que j'ai peut-être encore des
petites choses à dire en vingt secondes
douchka se transforme en princesse de
seine sous l'oeil admiratif de ses
enfants elle avait pendant le passage
des autres chanteurs et groupes de la
soirée douchka en coulisses se prépare
et se fait dorloter par l'un de ses fils
le grand moment est enfin arrivé et le
répertoire est éclectique
[Musique]
m
soudas
on s'aimait
m
il
oh
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard nous la
retrouvons à paris pour des rendez vous
professionnels
cette semaine je suis à paris parce que
j'ai plein de choses à faire tellement
dévoué
des télés des radios des rendez vous
aussi pour des projets nous nous rendons
chez olivier lejeune qui me propose une
pièce de théâtre qui s'intitule tout
bascule le théâtre c'est passionnant
j'aimerais beaucoup évidemment on est si
vraiment les téléfilms et
et au cinéma le téléphone sonne les
affaires reprennent à la voilà chez
l'acteur et auteur olivier lejeune connu
notamment pour avoir participé à
l'émission la classe hainaut la voilà
masdar quel voleur dans sa douche cas
découvre avec olivier la pièce de
théâtre qu'il a écrit et pour laquelle
il aimerait lui confier un roulage pour
qui tout bascule au même moment sa durée
c'est à dire en fait c'est le mariage le
plus court de l'histoire c'est à dire
c'est qu'un homme qui va se marier et
une heure et demie après il va divorcer
j'aimerais jouer c'est ça qui fera la
mise en scène j'espère bien il ne perd
pas une minute et se glisse déjà dans la
peau de son personnage
votre femme est dans l'aspirateur
attention où vous mettez les pieds même
en fait qu'est-ce qui va prendre mais
lâche voyons on vraiment trésor
aujourd'hui douchka esposito veut être
une artiste complète et populaire et
pour celles qu'il ya 25 ans brille est
au firmament des spectacles pour enfants
les portes semblent s'ouvrir à nouveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
douchka jusqu'à bienvenue sur le plateau
de tout le monde en a parlé
vous étiez le 26 juin 1963 à saint claud
sous le nom de bojidar cas esposito
alors parents célèbres votre mère
évidemment c'est l'actrice pascale petit
votre perle comédiens artistes gianni
esposito la famille de pascal petit
était assez particulière puisque son
père votre grand père s'était entichée
d'un gourou bulgare qui avait monté une
ferme bio et pour gagner de l'argent
pour faire fonctionner cette ferme
votre mère pascale petit bosser chez
carita il était rentré apprenti chez
carita pour mettre quelques deniers de
côté pour participer à l'acquisition de
cette fameuse ferme bio qui était le
projet de la famille voilà alors on va
voir l'importance des rencontres chez
les coiffeurs et dans les salons de
beauté dans votre famille et dans votre
vie puisque c'est chez carita que votre
mère qui travaille à l'époque rencontre
une femme de metteur en scène qui lui
dit vous devriez être actrice oui
française de gan qui était donc la femme
de raymond rouleau qui on est un grand
metteur en scène de l'époque qui a fait
former des comédiens de renommée
internationale dont par exemple robert
hossein a
a tout de suite remarqué maman et
j'ai dit mais vous avez un visage de
comédienne et maman j vous croyez vous
croyez pas du tout elle était hyper
timide en fait pas du tout elle se
sentait pas du tout prédestiné
effectivement elle va devenir actrice et
à 21 ans grâce au film les tricheurs
pascal petit devient une star alors à
l'avant première du film elle rencontre
gianni esposito voilà ils s'aiment 1
vous naissez et à votre naissance c'est
le gourou bulgare qui choisit votre
prénom bojidar cas ce qui veut dire dieu
en bulgare non ça veut dire don de dieu
et votre mère quand même c'est un peu
compliqué comme noël vous surnomme
douchka oui j'étais petit monde
notamment savent c'est un surnom c'est
même un prénom 1 500 comme tout et puis
alors votre père d'udjani esposito qui
lui aussi était assez sous l'affluence
du du bulgare tombe dedans l'ascétisme
total à un moment et votre mère se sont
délaissés oui c'est à dire que bon il a
eu un engagement spirituel qu'un homme
marié n'aurait pas dû avoir et bon il
était mon père était quelqu'un d'entier
de profondément idéaliste profondément
mystique ses chansons le raconter
et donc c'est vrai qu'il avait ce côté
très très
très excessifs peut-être dans ses
premières années d' approche en tout cas
de la spiritualité et il a été un petit
peu dans l'excès et quand il a voulu
revenir en arrière c'était un petit peu
tard parce que c'est vrai qu'il a il a
délaissé sa femme un temps et que maman
était une comédienne quand même qu'ils
voyageaient beaucoup c'est un métier à
risque
c'est sur pied c'est vraiment en
exploser tout le temps en principe de la
séduction et voilà et donc ça n'a pas
été évident et un moment donné le couple
fait éclater votre mère prend un amant
elle est enceinte elle avoue tout à
votre père votre père essaye de la
rattraper elle va à l'aéroport pour dire
à son amant écoute voilà repart en
amérique tout seul moi je reste en
france avec avec mon mari mais en fait
elle est partie avec lui aux etats unis
et oui c'était ma cité le sort en a
voulu ainsi parce qu'elle est tombée
enceinte très vite c'était l'accident et
je crois que bon un moment donné quand
on est piqué par le virus de la passion
c'est fini c'est vrai que l'homme
qu'elle avait rencontré à berlin
c'était lors du tournage d'un film
corrida pour un espion c'était c'était
je dirais pas le diable mais il avait la
beauté du diable faisait 1 m 90 kg
denton ils étaient les cheveux noir
d'ébène un regard perçant une voix à la
barry white
enfin je veux dire et les produire des
acteurs américains des années 50
irrésistiblement boe
et redoutablement intelligent et c'est
vrai que le cocktail a été suffisamment
puissant pour envoûter ma petite maman
qui m'a quitté quand j'avais 3 ans voilà
donc votre maman vous qui tous vous
retrouver chez la soeur de votre père à
mesnil le roi et finalement vous passez
votre petite enfance avec votre demi
soeur oui je me suis découverte une
demi-soeur j'avais 6 ans donc elle
parlait l'italien puisque maman était
partie vivre à rome et un jour elle est
arrivée au clos du belloy 7,7 cette
maison c'était un manoir magnifique mais
où j'étais assez seul finalement puisque
mon père était souvent partie en gala
avec ma petite soeur ma demi soeur qui
parlait l'italien couramment et moi le
français
donc j'ai commencé par lui arracher sa
poupée d'amis là bas
voilà enfance rythmée par les visites de
votre père et par les passages éclairs
de votre mère voilà comme votre mère
chez carita vous c'est chez un coiffeur
que vous rencontrerez le destin en
l'occurrence et jean-louis david
jean louis david qui était non seulement
coiffeur mais photographe et là vous
entrez dans le monde du showbiz d'une
façon complètement inattendu il fait un
reportage sur les miss junior pour votre
beauté
quand il m'a vu il a dit tout de suite à
maman tafial un physique de mannequin
pourtant je ne faisais pas 1 mètre 80
bon il m'a présenté à john casablanca
qui était déjà le long de la vie on
délivre embauché personnellement en plus
oui il a dit allez pas assez grande mais
bon ce sera très bien pour les
reportages les studios photos et donc et
donc j'ai démarré
c'est vrai par la grande porte mal bien
malgré moi j'avais fait aucun casting
c'était comme c'est incroyable comme
votre mère avait démarré mais un petit
peu plus tôt parce que j'avais 13 ans
comme c'était vraiment très jeune et
j'étais bien contente de quitter l'école
pour un fait gagner un peu d'argent de
poche et là vous êtes quand même
douchka c'est délurée parce que à 14 ans
vous avez votre premier amant encore
c'est vrai que j'étais précoce mais
j'étais j'étais très précoce
physiquement oui voilà à 12 ans je
faisais un mètre soixante huit mois gt
gt une petite lolita entre guillemets à
18 ans vous retrouvée enceinte de lui
apporter
oui oui parce que en plus je faisais de
l'anorexie comme tout les mannequins
jeune mannequin cela la hantise de
prendre des kilos il fallait être comme
ça je m'étais déréglé en fait à force de
ne pas manger et c'est le danger
d'ailleurs est en fait c'est pas du tout
anodin moi je suis tombée enceinte et je
me suis pas rendu compte que j'étais
enceinte moi parce que je crois que
j'étais j'avais un dérèglement hormonal
nation et alors à cette époque vous
faites une expérience de nir def
expérience c'est à dire que le riz voyez
la mort en fait dans le couloir avec la
lumière blanche au bout vous quittez
votre corps et c'est vrai que j'ai
conscience de vies antérieures non moi
j'ai analysé ça bien des années après en
fait sur le coup j'ai cru que j'avais
fait une hallucination lié à mon malaise
et est en fait quand mon coeur s'est
arrêté que j'avais plus pour le docteur
chercher mon pool trouvait page est en
train d'avaler ma langue et et moi je me
suis senti vraiment aspirer comme ça et
tout d'un coup boudé doublé à 2 mètres
sur mon corps c'est quand des années
après en fait que j'ai compris que
j'avais vécu un truc que d'autres gens
avaient vécu en lisant ce bouquin du
fameux professeur scientifique raymond
nous dire américain alors là vous
quittez le mannequinat parce que vous
êtes trop petit en fait pour défiler
vous retourner au lycée vous prenez des
cours de chant
j'ai toujours eu cette ambition de
chanter
le faire du lyrique et là vous entrez
dans l'univers féerique
je sais pas de disney à l'époque votre
mère pascale petit vie avec l'ancien
secrétaire de sheila le producteur de
karen cheryl imbert ibak dit mémé ibak
est alors semer mais ibak propose au
patron de disney europe d'avoir une
égérie qui incarne la marque disney
alors ils pensent à karen cheryl amants
ils pensent à chantal goya il pense à
dorothée mais elle refuse tout et vous
il n'est pas très chaud en vue lors
qu'il vous a toute la journée auprès de
lui évidemment il est pas très chaud
pour vous devenir l'égérie de disney il
pense que vous ne faites pas assez puis
de fond ses moyens on peut dire il avait
l'impression que j'étais pas assez
populaire entre guillemets dans le
concept quoi c'est vrai que ma mère a
beaucoup oeuvré pour parce que c'est
vrai que cette perspective de contrats
étaient quand même une chance
extraordinaire oui et que j'avais le
profil alors à l'époque j'étais
blondinette bon j'avais un petit profil
d'alice au pays des merveilles et et
tout le monde se disait c'est dommage
donc qu'elle passe pas le cas si léger
qu'il m'a quand même fait passer un
casting il m'a pas fait de cadeau et
voilà c'est moi qui étaient choisis
parmi quatre ou cinq jours était proposé
à 20 ans vous donnez princesse disney
ont dit officiellement que j'avais
dix-sept parce que 20 pensent à un peu
trop y jeu c'est vrai que le fait qu'on
me rajeunit au départ ça m'a ça m'a un
petit peu gêné
ouais parce que je sortais de l'univers
justement j'étais mannequin alors quand
on est mannequin quand on a 15 ans c'est
le contraire on rit on vous maquille on
me les fossiles vraiment hélas est l
inverse on mettait les chaussettes les
que les chaussures à brides la barrette
dans les cheveux dès que j'ai enlevé bon
il venait me la remettre et puis on me
rajeunit c'est donc quand j'arrivais en
plateau de télé devant jean pierre
foucault michel drucker j'étais très mal
dans mes pompes
et tout le monde croyait que j'étais un
peu nunuche mealamu juillet le
personnage très bien mais j'avais un
côté j'étais pas toujours très bien dans
ma peau dans les interviews suivant le
moment et parfois ça se ressentait mais
en même temps dès que dès qu'on disait
moteur ça partait dans l'énergie aie et
le show vous avez fait un vrai carton
vous allez vendre 7 millions de disques
oui mais mais a eu l'idée de prendre
d'aller chercher une chanson qui avait
déjà fait ses preuves en amérique latine
qui s'appelait uno massonneau de ses
camarades et
donc il a adapté en faisant 1-1 2-3
mickey donald et moi et là après la 2e
tv en fait on est on à démarrer tout de
suite en fort au niveau des ventes alors
célébrités assez rapide finalement oui
ma inattendue on va dire qu'ado est
alors quelles ont été les réactions de
votre entourage votre mère a gravi
j'imagine bas tout le monde était
content qu'on n'a pas trop le temps de
se poser la question au fond cependant
pendant 6 7 ans je passe d'un masseur
votre temps de tout le monde était
content ouais tout le monde était ravi
alors vos relations avec les médias
c'était comment parce que en fait la vie
de vous racontiez dans les médias
c'était comme une vigueur l'été un petit
peu réécrite par par la compagnie disney
non oui à disons qu'on a et créer une
petite légende
parce que un bep rybak mon producteur
voulait pas dire que j'étais la fille de
mes parents ah oui parce qu'il fallait
justement que je reste la petite
française populaire
la grande soeur de michael avait raconté
que dans la légende que j'étais passé un
jour sur les champs elysées j'étais
monté tout candidat rencontré taper à la
porte de walt disney et que j'avais
demandé à voir armand big le président
de disney et que l'a conquis par mon
charme mais ma jeunesse
eh bien ils m'avaient signé un contrat
d'exclusivité alors c'était un peu gros
les journalistes savaient que ce n'était
pas tout à fait vrai mais jouer le jeu
pour certains et puis voilà
alors question argent faisait de
l'argent à cette époque quand on a 20
ans et qu'on gagne 50 mille francs ou
car entre 40 et 50 mille francs par mois
c'est ce que je vais revenir les pommes
c'était super bien quoi parce que c'est
pas assez d'argent facile
c'est pas assez pâle usine choisir ça
m'a pas c'était dur quand même c'est
vrai que la fois bon mais en même temps
c'est pas non plus les fortunes de ce
qu'on peut imaginer parce qu'à un
premier contrat voilà alors quel est le
meilleur moment de cette époque je pense
en 86 quand j'avais vraiment dépassé on
va dire les classes de la danse du chant
que j'étais à l'aise dans les interviews
que je comme que je commençais à
maîtriser un petit peu mon histoire et
que je m'éclatais en scène avec les
personnages les shows
l'impact voir la magie de la scène voilà
et le pire moment de l'époque c'est
quand en fait je rêvais de pouvoir
chanter d'autres chansons que j'ai par
exemple enregistré nuit d'été qui est
une chanson qui avait été écrite par
didier barbelivien et qu'ils étaient
super magique c'était une chanson pour
elsa qui aurait fait un carton comme
t'en va pas et que j'ai pas pu j'ai pas
pu garder cette magie c'est
l'authenticité de cet enregistrement
parce que c'était pas dans le concept et
qu'on m'a plaqué des choeurs sur la voie
qu on may vary spidey lalande et que à
l'arrivée j'ai pas eu la satisfaction
artistique d'avoir h 30 c'est très
frustrant quand je voyais marc lavoine
en télé janvier patrick bruel que je
voyais lio avec ses mini jupes et ses
jolies gambettes usées pourquoi pas moi
voilà il c'est là qu'en allant chez le
coiffeur toujours les cours coté vous
rencontrez angelo di napoli
alors là c'est le coup de foudre tout
comme on peut le vivre à 25 ans sur mais
le problème c'est que vous savez pas qui
il est marié qu'il a un enfant il
n'était pas marié mais c'était tout
comme
et que sa femme était enceinte et sa
compagne ça c'était la mauvaise surprise
mais je laisse subtilement après bon
comme j'étais mordu comme voulait le
virer un jour il vous a au charme quoi
voilà c'est ça je l'avais dans la peau
c'est vrai qu'à 25 ans la peau c'est
important merci hein
alors voilà en 1988 j'en ai marre de
faire que du 10 n'est là le nouveau
patron sisman vous propose de faire
évoluer votre carrière à condition que
vous quittiez mais payback
il vous signer directement avec disney
cars sisman il voulait une artiste
signée walt disney production walt
disney
et parce qu'il était un numéro un et un
mini bac était un numéro un ici c'était
d'une de numéro un qui se rencontraient
et donc ça a été voilà un petit peu
deux ego fort de personnalités fortes et
voilà moi je me suis trouvé au milieu et
donc pierre sissmann est venu vers moi
m'a proposé de contrat en direct et là
j'ai pas voulu faire un enfant dans le
dos à mon producteur et en plus c'est
vrai que j'ai été beaucoup plus
préoccupé à la fin de ces quelques
années au bout de la sixième année par
le fait de vouloir me marier et 2
et de partir un petit peu à l'ombre des
projecteurs et de me consacrer plus à ma
vie privée et ma vie de tous les marier
avoir des enfants
en 90 vous quitter le métier pour
devenir maman voilà trois grossesses en
trois ans oui parce que j'étais pressé
de revenir mais malheureusement angelo
di napoli vous trompe et il a des dettes
oui enfin bon appartement elle saisit
quand même oui on va dire qu'on était
jeune et que avec eux
et que voilà c'était peut-être pas
quelqu'un qui était fait pour le mariage
si tôt et je lui peut-être aussi mis la
barre un petit peu trop haute aussi
voilà moi j'ai été un petit peu
irresponsable et lui on va dire à
l'aller alors là vous rencontrez la boue
rencontrer vladimir vous installer dans
un hlm de la ville de paris mais
l'histoire tourne pas 63 rue petit way
avec ses terrains si là vous mettez un
petit peu pas plus que la pas plus que
la fimat quoi je veux dire j'étais un
petit peu perdues je savais pas qui
j'étais je n'étais une petit peu une
poupée vivante enfin c'est péjoratif de
parler comme ça mais c'est vrai que
c'était un personnage était un
personnage vivant au milieu d'un univers
virtuel après j'ai été maman la mamma
italienne par excellence j'aurais trouvé
mes racines un peu trop parce que
c'était excessif on va dire trois
enfants en trois ans et demi c'était
voilà un conséquent pour plein de
raisons je regrette pas aujourd'hui j'ai
trois enfants magnifiques mais bon à
cette époque là c'était lourd de
conséquences au niveau de ma carrière et
et quand je me suis retrouvée finalement
au jeu avec un divorce
plus d'argent plus d'appartements plus
rien quoi l'oiseau sur la branche avec
avec trois petits bébés en bas âge ça a
été la galère et là haut c'est là où
j'ai manqué de sagesse et
et je suis parti comme ça dans une fuite
un petit peu en avant et je fumais pas
beaucoup mais suffisamment pour que ça
me chloroforme et que ça me
des collectes donc donc samassa mahan il
est un petit peu peut-être ma réactivité
et petit à petit j'ai plongé
quel difficile parce que vous vivez des
histoires d'amour c'est désastreuse on
peut le dire oui
voilà j'avais tout faux ouais donc je
veux dire quand on vit des choses
difficiles comme ça faut faire du sport
faubert de l'eau faut pas fumer ni de
cannabis tabac faut être dans une il
faut être combatif
or moi je l'étais je l'étais pas et je
crois que réellement dans la vie pour se
construire il faut être seul pour
démarrer sa vie et m'a finalement j'ai
quitté le lycée pour devenir une artiste
dans une voie là dans une équipe
après je suis devenue maman finalement
je m'étais jamais retrouvé en face de
moi même face à ma vie d'adulte de
futurs adultes et c'est là où je me suis
retrouvé face à ma vie avec d un tel
poids sur les épaules d'éden
enfin des petits enfants me dire que
j'avais pu liberté une femme quand elle
a des enfants qu'elle a pas d'argent ça
veut dire que on est bloqué à la prison
donc pendant les guerres toute la
période où il était en bas âge étaient
avec eux donc je sortais pas j'étais
isolé
son carnet d adresses seul et après
j'avais la plage des horaires des
enfants c'est-à-dire qu'à 4 heures
d'après midi ma journée s'arrêtait et
donc c'était un enfin pour moi pour
l'artiste un enfer un enfer parce que
vous êtes retrouvés un moment vendeuse
ou de vive au lit c'est à dire les
années 80 n'était plus à la mode
quand j'allais voir les gens on disait
bah oui mais
à l'image de disney
j'étais un peu paumé en plus voilà donc
pour trouver vendeuse ouais je me
retrouve en deux je me retrouve à devoir
lâcher mon appartement parce que parce
que dur dur je peux pas payer mon loyer
et je me retrouve donc je me dis
maintenant qu'est ce que je fais je n'ai
pas le choix je me suis dit maintenant
mon objectif c'est récupérer un
appartement à mes enfants donc je vais
travailler comme tout le monde et puis
la vie va me sourire
et là j'ai commencé à me reprendre en
main mais vous faites la première
compagnie qui est une émission de télé
réalité de tf1
ça vous a aidé sa beaucoup oui parce
qu'à l'époque qu'est ce que je pouvais
faire de mieux que la télé réalité vous
en rapporter un peu d'argent
voilà je suis passé des lectures de
théâtre ça marchait pas voilà j'étais
pas plus mauvaise qu'une autre mais je
sais pas c'était comme ça c'est des
cycles 1 dans la vie j'allais au devant
des castings ça marchait pas en revanche
bon un jour j'appelle la production donc
deux premières compagnies et endemol et
j'y vois là je m'appelle douchka
le lendemain il me reçoit v et le
surlendemain je signe mon contrat
voilà et voilà je fais une embellie au
niveau médiatique au niveau financier à
tous niveaux et c'était donc posé les
bonnes choses
une bonne chose aujourd'hui vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque disney douchka
non je ne suis pas nostalgique parce que
finalement il m'arrive plein de choses
formidables et
je serai nostalgique si j'étais si je
faisais plus rien aujourd'hui
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
ne referiez pas pareil j'imagine que
vous signeriez le ceclr système vous
proposer chez disney je donnerai la
préférence à ma carrière plutôt qu'à va
quand même passion amoureuse est
clairement jeu
voilà je pense qu'à l'évocation
amoureuse là c'est vrai vous avez quand
même c'est tombé sur lui mais quand même
tu pas toujours facile pénale qui lui
taper dessus quand même bon j'ai vécu
des drames
mais mais peut-être qu'il fallait que je
passe par là pour comprendre ce que
c'était que le prix de la passion et les
limites
des choses le jour vous allez mourir oui
qu'est ce que voulait qu'on marque sur
vos tombes et mais toujours plus fort
pour être sûr des mérens et peut-être un
joli je sais pas je veux dire devant la
forme oui oui je sais je je crois que
j'ai jamais été aussi bien dans mes
baskets quoi récolter 13 au vaudreuil
dans mes baskets
merci merci et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de leonard youtube abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu